avec l'autre blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
merci d'être avec nous alors c'est la
pression des milieux économiques et des
entreprises club blanche maison qui
dicte la réouverture au sein de ces pays
face aux deux réserves quand même
puisque les gouvernements au début de
l'épidémie s'était engagé à donner la
priorité à la protection des vies
humaines
et ça reste bien entendu toujours le cas
bien sûr les milieux économiques se fait
que l'activité reprenne et on pourrait
dire en schématisant un petit peu que
les gouvernements chaque gouvernement
est pris entre deux feux celui du
pouvoir médical qui est très prudent et
killy ne déconfit n'est pas parce qu'il
pourrait y avoir une deuxième balle une
sorte de tsunami on ne sait jamais et
puis les milieux économiques qui
craignent la multiplication des
faillites et un chômage de masse et qui
finalement 10 si on continue comme ça il
y aura plus les chômeurs à confiner donc
les gouvernements sont amenés à faire la
part des choses
d'ailleurs en tenant compte également de
leur opinion publique
parce que les opinions publiques se
manifeste et notamment mon as
manifestées dans les sondages et dans
les élections et dans les actions
naturellement régulière alors la
situation est différente suivant les
pays
bien sûr pour deux pays voisins au sud
de la france l'italie et l'espagne
il n'est pas question de rater la saison
touristique
tout simplement parce que le tourisme
représente entre 13 et 15% de leur
richesse nationale de leur pnb et par
conséquent il y aura certainement des
pertes mais il n'est pas pensable de
perdre 15 % du pnb pour la grèce et
c'est beaucoup plus puisque c'est près
de 30%
et là encore c'est la raison pour
laquelle ces pays ont réouvert leurs
plages leur restaurant leur hôtel leur
café et ceci va continuer d'être
réellement en respectant les
les gestes barrières et en respectant la
distanciation physique pour l'allemagne
c'est un peu différent notre autre
voisin puisque la chancelière a essayé
de prolonger le confinement
par souci de sécurité et puis c'est un
petit peu heurtée aux aux ministres
présidents des différents länder qui
avec les entreprises voulait rouvrir il
fallait absolument rouvrez l'économie et
se trouve qu'en allemagne pays fédéral
ce sont les länder qui ont le plus de
pouvoirs en matière de santé il a donc
fallu faire un compromis est finalement
l'allemagne avec une certaine prudence
euros ses frontières et comme ça a été
dit tout à l'heure dans votre sujet le
gouvernement français doit annoncer
jeudi prochain ce que sera la phase
suivante à partir du 2 juin et l'on
verra ses hôtels et restaurants sont
ouverts en tout cas en zone verte
alors ce sac est en avance on constate
en ordre dispersé cela peut-il provoquer
selon vous un retard dans la
restauration du marché unique
si le marché unique
il existe toujours puisque les produits
circulent tout à fait et librement et
notamment dans la zone euro bien entendu
avec la monnaie unique que les services
dématérialisés
circulent aussi tout à fait librement et
que le problème ne se pose que pour les
personnes et en effet il faudra à
l'avenir probablement des comptes et que
ce sera possible
rétablir la libre circulation des
personnes est actuellement des
négociations sont en cours des
négociations bilatérales les pays des
gosses y en deux par deux pour respecter
la réciprocité les pays que vous avez
cités tout à l'heure pour des raisons
d'ouverture au tourisme vont lever les
restrictions au 1er juillet est bien là
la france les bras serrés ses propres
restrictions vis-à-vis des
ressortissants de ces pays
à la même date il y aura donc une
réciprocité et je crois que le marché
unique de cette phase on retrouvera sa
réalité
avec ses 4 les
perdez dans quelques mois alors l'argent
mis sur la table par chaque pays
l'argent mis sur la table par l'europe
dans son ensemble ces mesures seront
elles suffisantes
écoutez elles ont le mérite d'exister
d'abord les états membres dans l'urgence
pris des mesures et on a entendu ce
matin le ministre des finances français
cité une enveloppe globale de 750
milliards d'euros qui a déjà été mise
sur la table si l'on additionne toutes
les mesures qui ont été prises au plan
national
alors maintenant au plan européen et
bien au plan européen
nous attendons une proposition de la
commission qui doit intervenir dans
normalement dans deux jours
elle inclura probablement tout ou partie
de la proposition franco allemand la
proposition faite par la chancelière
merkel et par le président de la
république française qui porte sur 500
milliards d'euros avec un mécanisme
président novateur qui consiste à
autoriser l'union européenne en
l'occurrence la commission à faire un
emprunt sur les marchés financiers à
inclure le montant de cet emprunt dans
le budget de l'union européenne et à
faire en sorte que avec ces fonds et
bien les régions et les secteurs les
plus impactés par la crise du grenat
virus puisse toucher des subventions pas
des prêts pas des prêts ce sont des
dotations budgétaires et ultérieurement
lorsque l'emprunt sera arrivé à maturité
l'empreinte 500 milliards d'euros eh
bien ce sont les états membres qui
rembourseront probablement avec la clé
budgétaire qui rembourseront c'est cet
emprunt là dessus évidemment il ya cinq
états que l'on appelle frugaux notamment
l'autriche les pays bas la suède et le
danemark qui ne sont pas d'accord pour
deux raisons église nous ne voulons pas
augmenter le budget de l'union
européenne
les raisons et deuxième raison sur le
plan de la technique financière est un
petit peu curieux de transformer des
emprunts en dons et par conséquent nous
voulons distille que cela l'emprunt
servent à faire des des prêts aux
régions et aux secteurs les plus
affectés
il est probable que les etam en trouvant
un compromis peut-être qu'il faudra
isoler la partie résultant de cet
emprunt communautaire dans le budget
peut-être faudra-t-il faire un budget
bis peut-être pourra-t-il faire des
compromis
j'imagine que dans la proposition de la
commission certains pour promises sont
déjà esquissé notamment avec un volet
près donc emprunter près et avec
peut-être une enveloppe qui montera au
total jusqu'à 1000 milliards d'euros ce
qui s'ajoute aux 540 milliards d'euros
déjà décidée par les mines et des
finances de l'union européenne en avril
et puis par ailleurs comme vous le savez
la banque centrale européenne a décidé
de faire des achats d'obligations
publiques et privées et que ces montants
sont tout à fait considérable puisqu'il
s'agit d'un montant de 750 milliards
d'euros pour l'année 2020
alors est-ce que ça suffira personne
n'en sait rien mais il faut d'abord se
mettre d'accord sur l'utilisation de ces
moyens de ces instruments et notamment
sur la proposition de la commission qui
va arriver mercredi soir et puis ensuite
on verra bien je pense que s'il faut
ajouter des moyens supplémentaires
les pouvoirs publics nationaux et
européens
le ferons merci claude blanchemaison
d'avoir été avec nous